so i started my own investigations with
the animals we know best dogs and cats
and i started asking people if they've
ever noticed their animals pick up their
intentions and lots and lots of people
said yes and the most testable of these
was people saying that their dog knew
when they were coming home the dog again
wasted a door or a window and the people
at home would know when that person was
coming back i did a survey and found
about 50 percent of dogs do this so
we're not talking something very very
unusual i'm quite sure a lot of people
listening to us now will have dogs that
do this
rupert sheldrick welcome to the show
good to be with you
how do you describe what you do for work
i'm a biologist and i do scientific
research i write about it in books and
in papers in peer-reviewed journals
i do experiments i make observations um
i go to scientific meetings so that's
probably my main day job
it's diverged a little bit from
some of the more typical areas of study
in those fields though
yes i've um
you know i investigate things which
most scientists don't either because
they want to stay within the
fairly narrow confines of institutional
orthodoxy
or um
because these are new areas of research
for which it's hard to get funding and i
like exploring areas where there's been
very little exploration before so that
that's my particular
thing i mean for many scientists they
prefer working in crowded areas of
science where there's lots of other
people doing similar things where it's
easy to get publications and grants and
so on
um
but i i explore lesser-known areas of
the natural and the psychological worlds
morphic resonance which is one area of
research in particular that you've come
up with
how many other people
are working within that field
well in terms of actual experimental
research i think approximately zero
um um
the uh
there are a lot of people who are
interested in the idea
the idea is that there's a kind of
memory in nature and that the so-called
laws of nature are more like habits
but when it comes to actually testing it
there have been quite a number of
experiments over the years which are
summarized in the new edition of my book
a new science of life
but right now
there are two or three people who are
planning some experiments in biology
labs and
with animal behavior
but no one's actually doing them as we
speak however there will be some
happening quite soon i hope what do you
mean by memory and habits
well the usual view of nature is that
it's governed by
eternal laws
that
at the moment of the big bang all the
laws of nature were supposed to be fixed
like a kind of napoleonic
code a cosmic napoleonic code
that's the normal assumption in science
and they've assumed to be the same
everywhere ever since
i suggest that the so-called laws of
nature um evolve along with nature they
weren't all there at the beginning i
mean after all it's only an assumption
no one was around at the big bang
taking taking scientific measurements
and if they had by a time machine
managed to get to the big bang they
would have evaporated instantly you know
billions of degrees centigrade
so it's just an assumption
um and
in fact when you think about it the idea
of laws of nature is very metaphorical
it's based on human laws and
only humans have laws and in fact any
civilized humans have laws tribes have
customs
so what i'm suggesting is a better
metaphor is habits and if nature has
habits so nature has to have a memory
and so what i'm suggesting is that
nature is full of habits crystals
crystallize the way they do because
they've crystallized that way before
and when a new crystal appears when
chemists make a new compound and it
crystallizes for the first time there
won't be a habit because it hasn't
happened before you may have to wait
years for a crystal to form but once
it's formed in one place it gets easier
everywhere else
likewise
if you train rats to learn a new trick
in newcastle
then rats all over the world should be
able to learn the trick quicker just
because they've learned it here in
england first
and the more that learn it the easier it
should get
and the influence of morphic resonance
is an influence of similar things upon
subsequent similar things across time
and space from the past to the present
so that's roughly what i'm trying to say
in this hypothesis and it leads to the
idea that every species has a collective
memory
on which individuals draw and to which
they contribute
and also that humans of course have a
collective memory which is very similar
to the psychologist jung jung's idea of
the collective unconscious
how do you separate out
habits and laws
well if you assume that a law is an
eternal changeless
thing then
crystals should crystallize exactly the
same way the first time or the millionth
time or the billionth time because the
so-called laws of nature haven't changed
um
but if
the rate of crystallization depends on
what's happened before then that looks
much more like a habit so you can
actually
test it experimentally most scientists
don't bother because they just take it
for granted that there are eternal laws
they they believe in eternal laws not
because they've thought about them but
because they haven't it's just a kind of
default assumption within science
how hard is it to test this stuff
experimentally
it's not that difficult i mean there are
a variety of tests with humans for
example um
it should get easier it should be easier
to do today's times word cross times
crossword puzzle tomorrow than it is
today because so many people have solved
it today um and actually people have
done experiments with crossword puzzles
they suggest that this really does
happen
um
so
and there are lots of lab tests with
animal behavior with cell cultures with
crystallization
the problem isn't that the experiments
are difficult to do is that morphic
resonance is seen as deeply heretical
within the scientific world
and
most scientists are afraid that if they
do anything heretical they'll get
drummed out of town and lose their
grants and their jobs and actually since
that actually happened to me um
it's not a totally irrational fear um so
uh the um
so most scientists are actually very
afraid of doing anything that violates
these taboos and i have had one or two
scientists working in reputable labs
who've been working on morphic resonance
experiments over the years
but
even in one case he was the principal
investigators leading institution in the
united states and he told me that to do
the morphic resonance experiments he had
to go in at night when there wouldn't be
any technicians around to ask what he
was doing and do these experiments under
cover of the night in a clandestine
manner so it's a ridiculous thing but
that's i'm afraid the situation what's
the taboo that it's crossing
it's crossing the taboo of eternal laws
of nature which is was built into
science in the 17th century in the 17th
century
ironically it was a theological
proposition the idea was that god made
nature god's the supreme law giver and
god's eternal so god's laws are eternal
um so it was a theological assumption
and it's now sort of hardened into
an assumption of materialist science
even though the theological reasons for
it have long since disappeared many
scientists are now atheists but they
still hold this kind of theological view
of laws outside space and time present
at the moment of the big bang
what are some of the most compelling
experiments that you went through let's
say someone hasn't heard of this before
what are some of the most convincing
experiments that you've done
well they're not necessarily the ones
i've done myself but they're ones that
other people have done in a way that
makes them more convincing i mean some
people who are very prejudiced against
this would if i come up with positive
results they say what do you expect he's
just getting seeing what he wants to see
um
there was a very long series of
experiments with rats that was started
at harvard
a very long time ago and for years they
were trying to see if rats could learn
more quickly something that their
parents had learned escaping from a
water maze
and they did they got
much faster to the first generation made
about 250 errors before they learned and
after 30 generations they were down to
about 20 errors this was a very big
effect
um
and they thought at first it was the
inheritance of acquired characters or
what's now called epigenetic inheritance
um
but then when people took up this
experiment in australia to check it um
they had a control line where they had
in every generation rats that
had parents that had not been trained
and they got better too so you breed a
set that does the experiment than one
generation that doesn't then you breed
another generation that does no not
quite that you have one uh one set of
rats where in every generation the
parents have been trained and you test
those rats you have another set where in
every generation the parents haven't
been trained you test the rats and then
you breed from the untrained parents and
and the next generation you test some of
the rats but you don't uh breed from the
tested rats
so that's the control line and they got
better too so it clearly wasn't passing
on anything through the eggs or sperm it
was something much more mysterious um
and i think that's a very good example
of morphic resonance
what happened
with the was this something to do with
milk bottle tops
yes um
well this was something that happened a
spontaneous uh
example in in about 1920 um
people in southampton noticed that when
they had milk delivered to their
doorsteps they used to have cardboard
tops on the milk bottles um
they found that when they picked up the
milk in the morning that
the top inch or so of cream it
disappeared from the bottle and
so people were upset about this and they
kept watch and they discovered the
offenders were blue tits blue tits had
discovered how to peel off the top and
then drink the cream
and
one thing that clinched it was when
people started finding drowned blue tits
head first in milk bottles
um so
you've got your milk bottle delivered on
a morning and you've got a free blue
tits sticking out of the top of it
exactly
and so
this aroused a lot of interest in
england and um blue tits are home loving
votes they don't migrate or move very
far
and
the scientists at cambridge who were
studying this got people from all over
britain through the radio newspapers
they got
bird watchers all over britain to watch
out for this and report when they saw it
happen
and so there's a unusually well
documented data on the spread of this
habit
and what they found was that the habits
gradually spread and then at an
accelerating rate throughout britain
and
the
the blue tits um
they found that when it happened more
than 60 miles from where it's previously
been observed they assumed it was an
independent discovery
and they found the rate of independent
discovery accelerated as time went on
they thought it might be something like
telepathy they thought it was not simply
birds moving around and telling other
birds
and
so it was a mysterious effect um
and it's just what you'd expect with
morphic
resonance and moreover in holland where
they also had milk bottle deliveries
melt deliveries stopped during the war
and after the war when they began again
dutch blue tits were doing this as well
and after the war when they began again
in holland um
blue tits all over holland immediately
started doing it even though um they
only lived through four years and none
of the ones after the ward had been
alive in the golden age of free cream
before the war
and interestingly enough this habit's
now dying out i i live in hampstead
london and we have milk deliveries to
our doorstep still today it's a much
better system than throwing away plastic
containers because they collect the
bottles wash them and use them again
and they deliver them always have done
in electric vehicles
so it's very eco-friendly system
anyway when we first started getting
milk delivered we had regular milk and
we had blue tits stealing the cream on a
regular basis
then
like lots of other people we switched to
semi-skimmed milk and i noticed almost
immediately the blue tits stopped
raiding the milk bottles uh it just
wasn't worth their while because there's
no cream on uh semi-skimmed milk so
so many people now have semi-skimmed
milk that there's habits dying out
bloody food pyramid
yeah food pyramid ruining these blue
tits habits
exactly
yeah i mean
what about what about birds in
swarms
when you see
starlings moving together is that
something similar
well
it's it's something i'm very interested
in when you see birds moving together in
flocks um
like starlings murmurations of starlings
they not only know where the neighboring
birds are but they know where they're
going to go
and you could say well they know where
the others are by keeping unblinking
attention on all their neighbors
although of course they can't see the
ones behind them
um
but they don't
even by knowing where the others are
they don't know which way they're going
to turn because they can turn in all
different directions
so the the whole thing is like as if
they're all within a field you know like
when you have iron filings in a magnetic
field
you move the magnet and all the iron
filings change their relation to each
other they're responding to a greater
field of which they're apart
well i think the birds are like that i
think there's a field of the whole flock
and the individual birds respond
to the um to the field of the like a
group mind kind of thing
um
i think that actually animal groups as
in general
have a field linking the members
together
um
and in fact i think that's the basis for
telepathy because they remain linked
even if they move apart like in a wolf
pack the adults usually leave the young
in the den with a babysitter and they go
hunting ranging over many miles
and then catching getting food to bring
back to feed the young
i think the bonds between the members of
the group are stretched i don't think
they break i think they remain in
connection at a distance and naturalists
have found that wolves seem to
communicate
at a distance way beyond the range of
sound or smell
um
and in a way that seems telepathic how
do they communicate or what what do they
do
well they know when the others are in
distress for example um
and they behave differently and if
they've got left behind sometimes
through injury they can find where the
others are
without the others howling to send out
sound signals
and i think this is normal you see and i
the reason
i got interested in telepathy because it
seemed to me a normal natural
consequence of animals living in groups
and
so i started my own investigations with
the animals we know best dogs and cats
um
and i started asking people with dogs
and cats and horses and parrots and
other domestic animals
um if they've ever noticed their animals
pick up their intentions
especially at a distance
and lots and lots of people said yes uh
and and the most testable of these was
the i it was people saying that their
dog knew when they were coming home the
dog again waited a door or a window and
the people at home would know when that
person was coming back
and of course the obvious explanation
would be well it's just routine or it's
hearing familiar car sounds but um so
a lot of people were convinced that
wasn't the case because they said they
had non-routine jobs and more than 20
women told me that they their husbands
worked
non-routine jobs as taxi drivers
journalists lawyers policemen etc
and would come home at non-routine times
but they always knew when their partner
was on the way because the dog again
start waiting for them sometimes 20
minutes in advance so they'd know when
to get on the meal so it was hot on the
table when their partner arrived and a
lot of people who were doing this we
just took it completely for granted um
and i did a survey and found about 50
percent of dogs do this so we're not
talking something very very unusual i'm
quite sure a lot of people listening to
us know will have dogs that do this
millions of dogs are doing it on a daily
basis all over britain and indeed all
over the world
so i set up experiments to because
telepathy is a taboo topic in science
it's not supposed to happen according to
the materialist theory of the mind which
is still dominant the mind's supposed to
be nothing but the brain or brain
activity all inside the head so your
thoughts or intentions couldn't possibly
influence a dog 20 miles away
so
materialists simply dismiss it as
superstition
you know ignorance stupidity
etc on the part of dog owners and
credulity etc
so they just dismiss it out of hand but
no evidence they don't need evidence
because they know they're right um
just on the basis of armchair arguments
um
anyway because i have to deal with
people like that all the time uh within
the scientific world um i have to do
particularly rigorous experiments so
with the dogs
i
found people whose dogs do this
or they said they'd do it
i had them go at least five miles from
home we filmed the place the dog waited
the whole time they were out
told them when to come home at a
randomly chosen time they didn't know in
advance by a mobile phone
and then they traveled by unfamiliar
vehicles um taxes uh a different taxi
each time
um
the most expensive aspect of this
research was the taxi bills
um
and
then from the cameras we could actually
see when the dogs started waiting and
sure enough
they were waiting much more when people
were on the way home then sometimes they
occasionally visited the window to look
at passing cats and things but
the waiting behavior was really clear
and they did it over and over again and
they didn't didn't do it every time
sometimes if they were sick or very
tired
or most
or if there was a [ __ ] on heat in the
next apartment they didn't do it
that doesn't prove they can't do it it
just proves they can be distracted but
in our tests about 85 of the time the
dogs accurately um
picked up when the end was coming home
over 15 minutes in advance and it's all
on film
so i think and this actually is one
online on my website anyone can see in
one of these experiments
so
i published a whole book about
unexplained behavior of animals called
dogs that know when their owners are
coming home
and i published these experiments in
peer-reviewed scientific journals as
well
for most people they don't have any
problem with this because they've seen
dogs do it or they know people who have
dogs that do it and um
and most people are curious and
interested but within the scientific
world this is intensely controversial
because it's not supposed to be possible
so
anyway that's one of the areas i
investigate and
it really
in the end the dispute comes down as to
what do you think science is is it a
belief system which is what some of my
colleagues seem to think or is it an
open-minded method of inquiry which is
what i'd like to think
and i think we can investigate a lot
more about nature than scientists
usually do
by breaking out of these taboos and
limitations
how many dogs did you look at
well i i collected stories on over a
thousand dogs with regular observations
and i did detailed filmed experiments
with three or four dogs
and
those are written up on in peer-reviewed
journals
would
scientists say that that is too small of
a sample size to be able to extrapolate
out i don't think so because with each
dog there were dozens of tests
um
you know if you were trying to find out
where the perfect pitch is possible in
humans
and you tested a few people and you
showed over and over again that they
really could identify a particular note
you wouldn't need to test thousands of
people to prove it's true and you know
it gets repetitive i mean
it i spent three or four years doing
these experiments and if something is
okay it's not enough you've got to spend
the rest of your life doing them well uh
not much incentive because
the people who don't want to believe it
don't believe it anyway and even if you
pile up more and more evidence as i have
done in many other areas of research
it doesn't make the slightest difference
they still say it's impossible
um
but still i think there's a reasonably
very good and convincing body of
evidence already
what is the difference between morphic
resonance and telepathy
well morphite resonance is a memory
principle that underlies animal
instincts the inheritance of form
collective memory
influence from the past whereas
telepathy is about connections in the
present it's about
it's usually to do with need
um
social needs uh individual needs
um to another member of the group for
example in the human realm
uh one of the commonest kinds
among women is with nursing mothers
many nursing mothers
have the experience that you know when
they're with their baby and the baby
cries their milk let's down it's called
the milk let down reflex and their
breasts start squeezing out milk for
obvious reasons to feed the baby
but some women when they start going
back to work or start leaving the baby
after a few months
of breastfeeding and they're still
breastfeeding but they now leave the
baby with babysitters
um
sometimes they find that they're
shopping or they're working somewhere
and their milk lettuce down there's no
baby crying nearby
um
and so uh they just assume they need the
baby needs them and their breasts have
somehow picked it up
and they used to just go home and they
were usually right now they ring home on
a mobile phone and then i've done
natural surveys and studies on this and
they're
very often right i mean way beyond
chance i mean it's like billion to one
against chance the odds of them doing
this just by coincidence
um so
that's one example and another example
i've investigated of human telepathy
is telephone telepathy
about 85 percent of the population
according to surveys that i and others
have done have had the experience of
thinking of someone who then rings
and obviously if you know someone's
going to ring at six o'clock and they
ring you're not surprised by that but if
you think of someone you haven't thought
of for a while for no apparent reason
and then they ring
you're likely to say something like it's
funny i was just thinking about you um
or sometimes when the phone rings people
know who it is before they look at the
caller id or answer it
this is really common and
the armchair skeptics who say this is
impossible um
first of all they
claim it doesn't happen and then when
you show 85 percent of the population
say it's happened to them then they say
well it must just be coincidence and
people just remember the times they're
right and forget the millions of times
they're wrong
um but
they've never done any research this is
just an armchair
a way of explaining it away and they got
away with this for a hundred years
after the invention of the telephone um
but i got rather sick of
so-called skeptics just getting having a
get out of jail free card of just saying
oh well it must be superstition or
ignorance or stupidity or people
misinter or false memory or whatever
so i decided to test their theory um
that is random coincidence and in my
experiments um
i've now done hundreds and hundreds well
thousands um
the
the caller say you chris if you're the
if you're the subject you'd give me the
names of four people you know well
friends or family members and you'd sit
at home with a landline phone no caller
id being filmed
then
i or my assistant would pick one of your
four
people at random from a random number
generator or throwing a die um
and then call them up and say think
about chris for a minute or two and then
ring him
um
so your phone would ring you'd know it
was part of this experiment you wouldn't
be able to predict who was ringing on
the base of knowing their habits because
they've been picked at random
um
and you'd have to say i think it's mary
hello mary and um you're on camera you'd
be right or wrong and if you were just
guessing you'd be right 25 of the time
one in four
in fact in these experiments the average
hit rate in hundreds of film trials is
about 45
so it's way above chance expectation
and people aren't right every time um
it's a very artificial situation and
people get a bit stressed by being put
on the spot in these artificial tests
but nevertheless this is a you know
immensely significant statistically and
now this has been replicated by other
people in universities in holland and
germany
and uh i now have a
thing that you can do on your own mobile
phone on my website there's a a take
part button and you can
log on and do it on your mobile phone
you have two callers you nominate two
people to call you and it picks random
times and the whole experiment happens
automatically so you can actually try it
yourself anyone listening as long as
they're in britain the us or canada can
try it themselves what's the website
what's the website
my website is called sheldrake.org
simple to remember o-r-g-org
um
so anyway this is one of the areas of
research uh i'm engaged in um
and
i
i summarize the um
some of this research in in my book the
science delusion where i look at the 10
dogmas of contemporary science and how
science could
become much more interesting and
informative
if people went beyond these dogmas
instead of being
imprisoned in a kind of straight jacket
of dogmatic thinking
um
so i'm very pro-science it's just i'm
not pro-dogmatic science i'm pro-free
inquiry in science and i think there
could be a lot more of it
the obvious question is
what's the mechanism that's making all
of this work is that
a question that can even be answered
well i mean what i'm postulating is that
there's an influence of similarity
across time in morphic resonance and
between members of social groups between
bonded members of the groups there's a
kind of resonance between the
individuals uh based on their
you know past history and they resonate
with each other
now
i'm sure there'd be changes in brains
that go on when this is happening and
you could probably detect them by brain
scans but that wouldn't necessarily tell
you
exactly how morphic resonance works
but
if you um ask the question well how does
gravity work well accepted scientific
phenomenon
you know some scientists say well
gravity works by gravity waves and
they've spent 50 years trying to detect
them you know people with gravity wave
detectors in deep underground mines so
very expensive long-term experiments
some people think they've found them
some people think they haven't yet found
them
so
and if you say well how does
electromagnetism work you know
how do you know then it works through
magnetic and electric fields well how do
they work well they work through
quantum fields through virtual particles
uh which are supposed to which appear
out of the quantum vacuum field and
disappear so fast you can't actually
detect them so
even conventional fields in science when
you press it how do they really work
it turns out to be surprisingly elusive
the answer is virtual particles that by
definition were undetectable or
gravitational waves um that uh may or
may not have been detected but are
certainly not obvious
um
so
and then people have in m theory and
super string theory which are the
leading theories in theoretical physics
today
um they have 10 or 11 dimensions instead
of the three dimensions of space and the
one of time that we're used to
um
and
so
they say well we would we'll be able to
explain gravitational electromagnetic
fields in terms of some ten-dimensional
superfield
but we haven't been able to find it yet
and
the problem with the theory is it has 10
to the power of 500 solutions it could
apply to 10 to the power of 500
universes so it's just a little bit too
prolific in terms of its um
predictions to to actually deliver
anything very concrete
so
it's not as if hard-nosed science has
got hard no simple 19th century type
mechanical explanations for for all
these things it doesn't um and the
explanations in modern physics are all
about explaining the visible in terms of
the invisible and what you can actually
experience with your senses in terms of
abstract mathematical spaces with
inconceivably inconceivable extra
dimensions
so
anyone who wants plain down-to-earth
simplicity isn't going to get it from
modern science in anything
it's funny to think when you put it like
that
the
the fact that there's a lack of an
obvious mechanism
undermining a theory itself
you're actually there's a lot of
different people that should be lined up
to be shot if that was the case there's
a few other theories that should go out
with the bathwater
well absolutely i mean one of the
dominant theories in current
contemporary cosmology
is that this universe is one of
trillions quadrillions of other
universes the multiverse theory was not
a shred of evidence that any of them
actually exist
and yet you can hold down a job as a
professor of physics in a respectable
university and you can say that and no
one's going to be too upset about it in
fact it's the orthodoxy
and
you know physicists can't explain
most aspects of the universe
so they've invented um
unobserved forms of matter and energy
called dark matter and dark energy which
are put in precisely to explain uh to
make the equations balance they give the
completely wrong answers so you can add
in as much as you like of dark matter or
dark energy until you get the right
answer and then you say wow it's worked
um but then if you say well what is this
dark matter and dark energy so we do we
don't yet fully understand their nature
in fact him to clue what they are
um
so
you know this is
modern physics is is by is very far from
being what
naive scientistic people who think
science has got all the answers people
like that
really don't know much about science and
if they do they might be a little bit
more humble about what they claim for it
it really does seem like
yeah people are not
the theories that we have they're not as
substantiated as they look when you
stress test them a little bit more going
back to the
human side of this ancestral trauma is
something that i'm seeing being spoken
about a lot on the internet at the
moment do you think this plays any part
in it
well there's very good evidence that
there's an epigenetic effect of
ancestral
trauma
you know this evidence came from famines
in sweden and holland in the late 19th
century or in the second world war
and
children born to mothers who went
through the famine
um you know were different size they had
different pronouns to diabetes etc
um and epigenetics is
since the beginning of the 21st century
has become a mainstream subject in
biology in the 19th only 20th century
the inheritance of acquired characters
inheriting what your parents have
learned or adaptations they've made to
the environment was completely taboo you
couldn't believe it it was a heresy and
people were drummed out of labs and
things since it was rebranded epigenetic
inheritance around 2000
um
it's become a major field of inquiry
so there's now no doubt that there can
be an inheritance of what
animals or parents in general have
learned
um
but there's also ways in which
there's a kind of
family memory of inherited traumas i
don't know if you've done any podcasts
on family constellation therapy no
what's that
um
well it's a it's a form of um
therapy for families which well for
people about their family um dealing
with
negative patterns in past generations of
the family
um one of the people who does it is my
wife jill pass who is
now doing zoom workshops on this and
there are quite a number of people doing
it i know about jill's work most because
you know obviously i see this at home
all the time
um
well
how it works is you have a workshop
say you went to a workshop
if it's an in-person workshop it might
be 20 or 30 people if you're doing it
online it might be 60 or 70 in a zoom
workshop
and
you want to work with your family i'm
assuming and for the purpose of this
argument so you'd pick somebody there to
represent your father your mother
brothers and sisters if you have any
and then you put them in like a stat
they're standing in the room in a kind
of tableau so if the parents were close
to each other you put them close
together if the father left
when you were young you put him far away
going out the door or something so
there's a kind of tableau of the family
dynamics
and
the people representing members of the
family often
feel things and emotions which aren't
their own personal emotions but which
are very much to do with that family now
that's no one understands quite how that
happens
but it often turns out
that people who have problems of being
suicidal excluding themselves from the
family
grossly dysfunctional behavior um
it often turns out that
these pick up on patents from previous
generations when someone was excluded
from the family either by suicide or
because they were sent away or they were
imprisoned or they did something
shameful and were never talked about
again or something like that
and
it turns out that what happens then is
the person running the workshop would
pick people to represent the past
generation the mother the father
brothers sisters they say the parents
generation or the grandparents
generation
and then they pick someone to represent
the excluded person and they bring them
back in
and the rest of the family sort of
welcome them back in they include them
instead of excluding them
this often has a remarkable healing
effect
on people in the present
sometimes you see people who suicidal or
who have this
dysfunctional behavior separating
themselves from the family
don't really know why they're doing it
and individual psychotherapy doesn't
help very much because it's not really
about them as individuals it's about a
family pattern that they're picking up
on
by a kind of morphic resonance that's
what most people who do this work think
that it works through morphic resonance
because there's no other explanation
that seems to fit the facts
so um
anyway that's one of the areas in which
trauma uh is inherited and that would be
more behavioral trauma rather than
metabolic trauma like starvation
um
and systemic family constellation work
is um
you know it's a very fascinating field
of therapy it's a growing importance and
significance at the moment
it's amazing how it's taking off and
it's taking off because
it actually helps a lot of people
in brazil
it's even been included in the legal
system
when they have family disputes in the
courts
instead of waiting three or four years
for an adversarial process in the in the
court
um they offer them an option to have
mediated uh family therapy
the court actually pays for this and and
so people
and they find that works much better
than having
family disputes played out in with
adversarial lawyers in courtrooms and
has a much more healing effect it's
cheaper and also
unplugs the court system a bit so um
so these things are taken quite
seriously in some parts of the world
including here
how does this relate to behavioral
genetics and heritability
does it mesh quite nicely or is there
some conflict
well heritability is pretty low for most
things i mean the
the human genome project
has now enabled the um
the genomes of
tens of thousands of people to be
sequenced and you can then look
say schizophrenia you can see is there a
schizophrenia gene you look at the
genomes of people with schizophrenia
and
you see what they've got in common it
turns out there's many genes that play a
small part and if you make complex
mathematical models and predict
the inheritability of schizophrenia on
the basis of genes
it's less than five percent you can't
predict i mean it's hardly it
is almost useless the predictive power
of genomics um
and that's true for things like breast
cancer even things like height
um
genomic genomics don't predict very well
and sorry just to drop in there what's
the difference between genomics being
able to predict inheritability with
parents because robert ploman's been on
the show and he's
highlighted
height is correlated 0.9 with your
parents bmi is correlated 0.3 he's done
the biggest twin and adoption studies in
history 20 000 pairs of twins he seemed
to say that a lot of heritability did
exist for both behavior and for and for
physicality well ploman's a very
interesting case he wrote a book called
your blueprint or something i forgot
what it's called
read anyway and and i've been to talks
by floyman so um he's an interesting
case because if you look at heritability
by comparing parents and children
there's very high heritability for a lot
of things
if you look at the genome
see he originally when he was doing this
work originally he just assumed well if
it's heritable it must be genetic it's
all in the gene name because he took the
assumption that heritability equals
genetic
um
and
in his earlier papers he just said well
that proves it's genetic the fact is
heritable
however in his book
the blueprint of life or whatever it's
called um
he starts with all these bold claims and
then when you get into it um
you find that he said well actually you
know there's been a bit of problem with
actually working this out with multiple
genome-wide association studies and
although schizophrenia is highly
heritable by looking at parents and
children when you look at the genes as
only five percent or something um
so what what we're saying here is that
although there's not much of a dispute
between the heritability from parent to
child the mechanism by which that
heritability occurs is a little bit more
up for debate oh absolutely and in fact
within biology it's only been in the
last say 10 years
that it's become clear that heritability
which is high for many things can
the the attempt to explain in terms of
genes
most people thought it was an open and
shut case of course it's genetic it
tells what else could it be what else
could it be it turns out it's not it
turns out that what it's called in
biology is the missing heritability
problem
so height for example is about 80
percent heritable you can predict
children's height taking into account
nutritional differences on the base of
the parent's height with about 80
accuracy
if you do it on the basis of genes
there's about 50 genes involved in
heights and you make the best
mathematical models you can only do it
with an accuracy of about 10
so that means 70 percent of the hair
inheritance of height is not explained
by the genes
yet we haven't got the technology
perhaps to be able to see it with
sufficient nuance i'm sure that these
are common arguments oh yes and and
they've got more down more and more
genes and more and more models and more
and more things and they've got it up
from about 10 to about 15 percent and
they hope with yet more expense billions
of dollars more they might get up to 20
but the fact is that a large chunk the
majority of the heritability is not
explained
their attempt i mean plumen would
suddenly say well it's just a matter of
yet more detail and we need it's more
elusive than we thought and we need
i would say
that's because most inheritance is not
based on genes it's based on morphic
resonance morphic resonance is uh highly
heritable it is you're more similar to
your parents than anyone else you have
more morphic resonance from them than
anyone else
but a lot of inheritance depends on
morphic resonance genes we know what
genes do they code for the sequence of
amino acids and proteins and they enable
you to make the right proteins and some
genes switch on and off other genes
that's what they do i mean this is
molecular biology
has in 50 years of molecular biology has
revealed very clearly what they do
what they don't do is program the
migratory behavior of a cuckoo the shape
of your face the you know the color
patterns on the wings of the feather and
uh the color patterns on feathers in
peacock's tails and things
they enable them to make the right
pigments for the right colors but the
patterns the shape the form the
instincts i think depend on morphic
resonance which organizes forms and
patterns the genes are essential for
making the right proteins but they don't
explain most aspects of heredity i
discussed this in my book the science
delusion there's a whole chapter there
on heredity and genes
it seems like
morphic resonance can occur across
species so we talked about dogs with
owners
and it can happen
through family whether it be parents to
children or grandparents ancestral
trauma stuff like that and it can happen
socially
you can choose the friends that are
going to ring you but it can't happen
universally we can't all just be
absorbing all of the morphic resonance
from
penguins that are in zoos and from a
line that was killed three hours ago so
there has to be some sort of selection
mechanism for you and it seems like
it's
social it's intent somehow it's like
some sort of connection have you thought
about how that works
well the basic thing about morphe
resonance is similarity um there's a
difference between morphic resonance
which is about memory from the past and
morphic fields which are what link
members of social groups together dogs
and their owners um
dogs make us members of their packs as
it were where they're social animals and
they adopt us as members of their packs
we've become part of their group
now when it comes to morphic resonance
from the past it depends on similarity
the field of a whole family is similar
to previous generations of that family
because there have been members of the
previous generation in this field the
parents were brought up in a previous
family with its own field each of them
had their own family field
or if the parents were separated and
remarried then more than one making it
more complicated
so the reason we don't uh
come under influence from penguins is
because we're not very similar to
penguins we are very similar to other
people and therefore the primary morphic
resonance working on is from the
collective memory of humans in general
and more specifically from people more
like us members of our families and
cultural and social groups that are most
similar to us
um
so um
then if you ask the question well
um
who in the past was most similar to me
um
then the answer is me
you're more similar to you in the past
and i'm also known as me in the past so
you'd have more crest morphic resonance
uh and i'd have more rupert morphic
resonance from the past um
because we're more similar to ourselves
and we're similar to other people too so
we have collective memory but individual
memory i'm suggesting depends on morphic
resonance because of the high
specificity in other words i'm
suggesting that our memories are not
normally stored in our brains in fact
they're not stored in the brain the
brain's more like a tv receiver than a
video recorder uh tunes into
its own past
um now that again again i have a chapter
on this in my book the science delusion
because one of the assumptions of
conventional science is that memories
are all stored inside the brain where
else could they be
um
that's based on the assumption memories
must be material things
and that's because contemporary science
is heavily rooted in the materialist
worldview which says everything's
material they haven't proved
everything's material just assume it
from the start therefore memories must
be material where are they in the brain
people spend 100 years trying to find
them and pin them down unsuccessfully
but they haven't for a moment stop most
of them stop to ask well are they really
in the brain at all they must be there
they must just be somewhere else
um
so these elusive memory traces are still
being sought for but i don't think
they're there
um
just like if i came to your house and
looked at your tv set and analyzed the
wires and transistors and tried to work
out what you've been watching last night
on tv if you were watching something on
tv
i wouldn't find any traces of the
programs in the wires and transistors
because that's not how the tv set works
um and of course brain damage can lead
to loss of memory
just as if i came and damaged your tv
set i could make it lose the sound or
lose the color or lose the pictures or
make it you unable to tune into channel
4 or something like that but that
wouldn't prove that all those programs
and all the people you see on the tv
screen are actually originating inside
the tv set it would merely prove the tv
sets necessary for the reception and
processing of the signals and the same
is true of the brain
with an if you have brain damage you can
lose memory but it doesn't prove you've
destroyed the memory stores
would it not be
simpler a simpler solution to presume
that memories are laid down in the brain
somewhere as opposed to them being
outside of it
well of course it's simpler i mean it
said everyone's oh yeah of course you
know like hard drives or
tape recorders or pages of a book
um we've got many
or things etched in stone
we've got many
easy parallels for memories being
material of course it's simpler and
that's why in the early 20th century
people said memories are stored in the
brain where else could they be
so simple everyone just accepted it was
true but the troubles and science the
simplest easiest answer that a child of
10 can understand isn't always the
correct answer and so
people have actually tried to find these
traces that this very simple theory
predicts and they failed that's what i
the point of what i was saying they
failed over and over again and and that
means that either the memory traces are
very very complicated and stored
holographically over large regions of
the brain so you can't pin them down in
any particular place that's one theory
today
so we can explain the fact we can't
actually find it by saying they must be
everywhere and nowhere in particular
the other theory which they haven't on
the whole considered is the one i'm
putting forward they're not stored in
the brain at all
um
and um
but they're transmitted by invisible
transmissions now
in the 19th century early 19th century
were you know when
people were thinking of simple brain
theories
the idea of invisible transmissions was
inconceivable but we now live in the
middle of them in front of me and you at
this very moment the air is full of
invisible transmissions of mobile phones
and radio and television signals and and
so on
and we don't say a tv can't work because
we can't see material things coming into
it um
so
when it comes to the brain a lot of
people revert to kind of 19th century
thinking
whereas all our modern technology is
about invisible influences working
through resonances at a distance
i'm just suggesting that some of these
might help us understand some of the
harder mysteries of biology
how does this relate to psychedelics
well
that's a rather different topic um
the um
i think there is a connection between
morphic resonance and psychedelics i
think psychedelics obviously
are chemicals that influence
neurotransmitter binding sites in the
brain and
the
the
tryptamine family of psychedelics which
include dimethyltryptamine dmt
um bind to
receptors for serotonin which is
5-hydroxytryptamine which is a
transmitted neurotransmitter and then
the phenothylamine
group of psychedelics which include
masculine
and ecstasy
well it's not really a psychedelic
ecstasy but those psychoactive compounds
bind
to dopamine receptors in the brain
so we know that these molecules bind to
receptors but and what they do is
disrupt normal brain function
but somehow they then open people's
minds up to
much more interconnectivity of different
regions of the brain and often highly
visual experiences
now
the
then then again you see there's the
question are these experiences generated
inside the brain or is the disruption of
normal brain function allowing
influences to come into the mind which
are normally blocked out by the everyday
work of the brain is it creating an
opening for something to come in from
beyond the brain or beyond the
individual person's psyche
many people who've taken psychedelics
feel that it's opening them to something
coming in not just generated within the
brain
now um
that takes us into the whole question of
the nature of consciousness and the mind
which we're not going to solve in the
remaining few minutes
um
but
the morphic resonance aspect of
psychedelics is this
if you take a particular psychedelic
like ayahuasca a psychedelic brew
that's been used in the amazon for
millennia probably
um then
your brain
is put into a similar state to the
previous people who've taken ayahuasca
most of them amazonian shamanic cultures
um and by morphic resonance you then
resonate to have a kind of collective
ayahuasca experience memory from those
who've taken it in that context
and you might then expect that people
who know nothing about the cultural
context of ayahuasca who takes in the
modern city for example
without knowing much about if anything
about amazonian culture
they might then have experiences that
are based on the mythic structures of
those amazonian tribes like seeing
jaguars
and serpents
and actually they do but this
experiment's been done and um
and i don't think it's because ayahuasca
activates jaguar cells inside the brain
i think it's because people are tuning
into a kind of collective memory of
people who've taken that same
psychedelic in the past
and so i think there's a component of
morphine resonance in psychedelic
experience it doesn't explain it all of
course but it does explain some of the
cultural inheritance that goes with it i
had a shaman on the show called hamilton
souther who runs a retreat in south
america and he was talking about the
resonance that occurs within groups when
people go
and take have a ceremony together and
take something like ayahuasca and that
they can come out of that and then
discuss shared experiences that all of
them went through and i saw you do this
and you saw me go over there and then
this thing arrived
and i suppose that ties in
well that would be a kind of telepathic
connection they're all in a similar
state they're they're in a group they're
bonded in a group they've probably
chanted together
which has a strongly bonding effect
um and so there'd be a telepathic
component as well to their visions
we've already discussed telepathy based
on being part of a group
um
and you know any ceremony run by a
shaman would would typically involve
some group building process and chanting
is the most common and and
and universal so that would all fit
perfectly well
with this approach
what was taking dmt with terence mckenna
like
well um
the actual experience of taking dmt uh
did it involved terence giving it to me
but then terence disappeared from
the field of view um and i was in
another realm altogether
um
in my experience what happened to me was
that
it was like an out of the body or a
near-death experience i i i went felt
myself going out of my body
i went through the center of a
flower a chrysanthemum flyer
and then i found myself in a realm of an
incredible beauty of shimmering colors
and changing forms and
then after a while
blissful
very bright colored and and a
wonderfully
happy realm
sublimely beautiful then i found myself
coming back into my body and stuff and
probably only 10 minutes later
and then when i described what had
happened to terence terence you've been
to the flower heaven
and since i'm very interested in flowers
and love flowers i mean i love the idea
of having going to the flower heaven
um
so
anyway that was um
terence was
when he took dmt he often described
machine elves or little people with
chattering voices and
fortunately or unfortunately i'd i've
never encountered machine elves i have a
bunch of buddies all of whom talk about
the machine elves yes yes
well i'm quite sure many people do and
in fact rick strassmann who
wrote a book on dmt called dmt the
spirit molecule
where he had a legal research program on
dmt i found that quite a number of
people did indeed encounter these
figures but not everyone it's not a
universal aspect of the experience
everyone's trying to get to flower
heaven
oh well not everyone's as keen on
flowers as i am and some of them may
prefer
some other 12 7. heavens oh yes or
possibly i i don't know
um
there's i mean there's many ways of
experiencing this but most of them have
in common this idea of kind of out of
the body and going into another realm
um and
i think they're similar to near-death
experiences myself and a lot of people
have near-death experiences um
which change their lives and of course
those involved don't involve any drugs
at all probably more dangerous than dmt
because you have to have a near fatal
accident or heart attack to have one
in my book science and spiritual
practices i actually talk about
um
near-death experiences in the context of
rites of passage or initiation um
i myself think that um
john the baptist was
doing this and in the new testament
john the baptist was people were
flocking from all over the holy land to
the river jordan where john the baptist
was had his simple procedure he hold
them under and i think he held them
under just long enough to induce a
near-death experience by drowning
and then he brought them up and their
lives were changed and
all in a matter of minutes no drugs
involved and you might have lost a few
there probably was an element of danger
but um
i think that in the 16th century when
there was a religious ferment in england
and um
baptism was started again by anabaptists
and baptists you know people who founded
baptist churches
their big thing was reinstating baptism
by total immersion
and
what happened to those with them what
they went round saying after they'd had
this ceremony was their lives had
changed they died and they'd been born
again and they'd seen the light
well these are literal descriptions of
near-death experiences
and so the only criticism of this
hypothesis is to say well
what they were doing was just symbolic
but why do something that's just
symbolic if you have the real thing it
only takes a minute longer um john john
the drowner doesn't have the same ring
as john the baptist though
no john the baptist well if one thinks
of baptism baptism is involving this um
then of course
it's um
it all makes total sense are you coming
to church on sunday we're going to
forcibly drown little timmy because it's
his first birthday and this is what
we're all going to go and watch we're
all going to cheer him on as he gets
forcibly drowned by the by the priest
well the point about baptists is that
they they didn't have in for they
rejected infant baptism and they said
you've got to do it as a conscious
choice you know when you're a 14 or 15
teenager or an adult
and um
and they do actually watch i mean
one of the very few southern baptists i
actually know is jerry hall
mick jagger's ex
um
and uh she's from texas
and i said to jerry you know what was
your baptism like you said well said in
my church that it was like a giant
aquarium so everyone could watch and and
and and i said well when you were held
under um you know
was it uh what was that like said it was
a lot longer than was comfortable she
said um
you know in his special dress and
everyone watching so um
this is um
i think probably today you know in the
era of litigation and health and safety
um they may not actually go for the the
full thing but i'm pretty sure that in
the past they were doing because how
else can one explain the way that
baptists were their whole thing was
dying and being born again
and
and people who've had near-death
experiences who've died and been born
again most of them say it's totally
changed their lives they've lost the
fear of death they've become much more
spiritual people and so on um
and so i all this makes sense to me
anyway we seem to be um
running out of time uh chris oh good
rupert sheldrick ladies and gentlemen if
people want to check out more of your
stuff your website and you've just
released two new books as well recently
oh yes well might as well well let me
talk about the one the three i've talked
about today the main one so the science
delusion which is the one where i look
at the 10 dogmas of science including
about inheritance and
and psychic phenomena and the laws of
nature
science and spiritual practice about
seven different spiritual practices
including meditation
singing and chanting and pilgrimage
which have measurable beneficial effects
and
the most recent one ways to go beyond
and why they work where i deal with
seven more spiritual practices including
spiritual effects of sports
learning from animals
spiritual openings through psychedelics
and fasting
so
all of these cover a wide
well they cover seven different
practices in each book
and if anyone's interested in following
up i have a youtube channel as well as
well as my website and many podcasts and
youtubes which are all available free
amazing thanks rupert
good to talk chris
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here for a
selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few months and
don't forget to subscribe
makes me very happy indeed
peace
you